The Joe Rogan experience,
a lot of times,
man,
people don't think about it that way
because you think of morning is like
when you have to go to work.
It's human male.
Is this what?
Talking about human nature and I was
just playing.
Come on.
How could that be possible?
Let me see that box.
Taste it.
It's on that box.
It's right on the box.
Oh,
it fell off.
No,
it's missing.
It's probably who.
Wait.
Who was here last?
Oh,
it's probably dunkins
nails.
You imagine if you're.
Do you want a podcast with someone?
You watched them trim them.
How's your doing?
As you're doing like what the fuck are
you doing with those gross thing and
then it will be over somewhere in this
area.
Scanning the rest of the table.
Now I'm trying to find that one
who smokes joints with random strangers.
Who knows what kinds of fucking weird
fecal herpes you're passing around.
When I put a toenail on my friends bond,
once he hit it and it smells.
That's not a friend.
You're an enemy posing as a friend.
You're a terrible person.
It burnt and smelled like hair.
Once you go to Mexico,
you call going to Mexico.
Yep.
Be Down there.
So you want to get home and that's part
of it too,
right?
Part of it too is like the disconnect,
unplug,
unplugging,
and then,
you know,
recharging your brain and being out
there and the desolate surroundings
going 140 miles an hour over bumps.
What gives you.
There's another side of it too that
gives you appreciation.
I have a kid now,
but I know my brother says to you on
there,
you also see the people,
how they live.
There are kids,
amazing kids and they live in chicken
coops,
the Bluetooth coupon by a host.
They live in chicken coops.
And I'm not kidding,
I'm saying it's a blue chicken coop.
That's what it is.
And there's kids,
and I actually call,
this is my little story,
but I,
there's,
um,
the kids that never grow up always come
out of Ohio.
So there's a little road after you've
turned down to blue date,
the Blue Gate on the right hand side,
there's a blue chicken coop and it looks
like every year for 10 years the same
kids come out.
They never get older.
They don't have shoes.
They're smiling.
We hand them stickers.
I stopped them,
give them.
I give them candy.
I talked to him.
The he signs autographs,
you take pictures,
you go back the next year they look the
same age and they they live job telling
you chicken coop.
I can draw it for you,
right?
It's a fucking chicken coop.
It looks like it's.
It's a chicken coop,
but it's not funny.
But you appreciate.
You come back and sometimes you look at
your kids and other people have kids
make.
You have no idea how easy your habit.
Yeah.
And then sometimes the kid,
that chicken,
we'll go to the dump and that's where
they find metal and they find scrap and
they take the aluminum cans and they get
their money and they're happy to.
They're happy.
They don't.
They're not negative.
They're not pissed off.
I think part of the reason was lucky
is I try to put myself in a position to
get lucky,
which is by playing more and believe it
or not,
it's van Halen that influence that on
me.
They were playing more than everybody.
They played three blocks from my house
in the backyard.
Now Monte,
I paid $1 to get in,
you know,
the singer Roth was blowing a tube
inside of this guy's drums.
And I'm going,
whoa man,
these guys are,
you know,
I was,
I thought they were great and everything
and they were playing cover songs and
they played a couple of originals I
think.
But what I was more impressed by at
least at that time was how often they
played.
They played every single night.
And I go,
we got to do that if we're going to have
any chance,
you know,
because my thinking was if we play more
than everybody might have to play free a
lot,
but if our name,
you know,
we might be able to brainwash people
into thinking they're supposed to like
us.
You know what I mean?
So,
and that's what happened though.
It was that persistence,
it was that playing free,
getting our name out.
We just happened to be at the whiskey
one night playing at during the week,
not even a big night or anything.
And the right guy was in the crowd that
law.
And he came up,
gave us his card.
And before you know,
we're,
we're recording,
we got airplay.
We don't even have a record deal.
I mean we,
our record deal was literally borrowing
15 grand from some guy named Fred.
Hey Fred.
Got 15 grand.
Yeah.
Okay.
So.
But we had a distribution deal.
But this manager we had called Ellen
Devon.
He was from England.
He used to work for virgin records.
He had signed Berlin.
He signed motley crew and a year before
this and I'm the.
Then they would sell these bands off to
big labels.
Well he got us on Camy t when we had no
deal and no local bands were on Kamia
team Kayla West with no deal.
It was just unheard of and,
but that,
I don't know what kind of connection.
So it was just a matter of you being
persistent and planning all the time and
this guy saw that's such an important
lesson for young people who are thinking
about doing something.
Sure,
Opportunity presents itself when you
just fucking buster and dream it and
dream it.
So this is one of the things,
especially talking to college students
that I love bringing up,
which is that,
and I'm the first to admit it,
like I have no fucking clue what I'm
doing.
Ninety nine percent of the time,
especially when I got started,
I still don't know.
And I've,
I've come to realize like I've got,
I've got lucky enough to meet some
pretty successful,
impressive people.
But like you dig under the surface,
we're all just hacking it.
Like we're all just figure,
expertise,
experience those things all help.
But like every one of us is a fallible
human.
All the conventions and rules and status
quo we know were created by other
fallible humans.
And there's no reason not to look at
that and go,
Huh,
does it have to be that way?
Or why is it that way?
And if the reason why is that's the way
it,
well,
that's a terrible reason,
you know,
and,
and when you see the world as being that
hackable,
so to speak,
like you start to realize,
all right,
well let's just,
let's actually question stuff.
And for,
you know,
I remember I was a freshman at Uva when
nine slash 11 happened for this
generation of millennials coming up.
We,
most nearly all of us,
one of our first really vivid memories
of the world was 9:11 this awful
tragedy.
And then we get into these two wars and
then think of all the authority figures
we've had in our life since that moment.
They've all at one point another either
misled us,
this sort of deceive this.
Um,
you've got the financial crisis,
you've got the housing bubble,
all these conventions.
Oh,
trust us,
we know we're doing.
This is the thing,
the American dream is buying a home,
go to college,
take on that student loan debt.
Don't worry,
there's a job waiting for you.
Every single one.
These conventions from,
from all these people in power have not
held up.
And so I think in particular,
millennials,
millennials look at that very
skeptically because we're like,
all right,
you know what?
So the conventional stuff didn't work
out for anything.
Like we have no choice but to realize,
you know what,
we're all just hacking it.
So let's,
let's really,
let's dive into the passion.
Let's,
let's figure out a better way to do
something.
Not Settle for the way that always been.